- Yeah, if the sun explodes,
and we're living in eternal darkness,
this is what's gonna save our lives.
- Some of us might starve.
(funk music)
- You want blue in your hair?
- Oh, that's nice and cold on my scalp.
- Is it supposed to burn?
- [Woman] Is it burning?
- [Man] No, it's not.
- Wait, why is one eyebrow a different
color than the other?
- There's no rules in glow.
- You look like a Miley Cyrus extra.
- Ready?
- Okay.
(electronic music)
(laughs)
- Dude, my hair lights up.
- Alright, give us the food.
- Oh whoa!
- Nice.
- This looks radioactive.
- When you peel it,
it's kinda interesting.
- Did your mother never tell you
not to play with your food?
- Yeah, but she never said don't play
with your glow in the dark food.
- Cheers.
- Mmm. Tastes futuristic.
- Definitely tasting neon-ness.
(laughs)
- This is the only time I would advocate
eating with your mouth open.
- This tastes sweet.
I would eat it in outer space.
- The chips look dope.
- Wait, are the chips glowing?
- I actually don't do meat or dairy.
- It's like neon dairy,
it doesn't really count.
- They glow in my mouth.
That was probably gross.
- But not really 'cause
it glows in the dark.
- It's crazy how much seeing something,
though, can effect the way you taste it.
- That is true.
- I can't tell if it tastes good or not.
The taste doesn't matter.
- It doesn't even look like food.
- There used to be these Play-Doh
kitchen sets you could buy
where you put a bunch
of Play-Doh in there,
you squeeze it out, it
comes out like spaghetti,
that's exactly what this looks like.
- This looks like Nickelodeon slime.
- This is delicious.
Like, I'm ready to consummate my vow.
I just hope it doesn't
consummate my mouth.
My senses are all scrambled up.
- Yeah, I feel like my
intestines are glowing,
and I wonder how it's
gonna come out later.
- Glow in the dark makes
everything more fun
and less flavorful.
- I was more interested
in playing with the food
than actually eating.
- For me, it's just
fascinating to be, like,
the way something is presented to me
will alter the way I taste it.
- Yeah, underneath the black lights,
it's like, yeah, I would eat that all day.
- Hell yeah.
- Just cause it looks cool.
- I'm just waiting for those
microwaves in Spy Kids,
where you just put like a bean in,
and then it comes out a cheeseburger.